when you peer into the micro cosmos and
sometimes hard to see past the cells
themselves flitting around fighting
surviving movement and shapes and colors
but we can see deeper and there's so
much more to see if you look beyond that
first level and into the cell itself in
the cytoplasm mysteries and curiosities
abound here in our macro world to see
inside an organism and we need expensive
scans or exploratory surgeries and the
micro cosmos
we can just turn on the light and see
some of the bizarre and beautiful
systems that these organisms have for
increasing their chances of surviving a
harsh and uncertain world so let's take
a look at some of the structures inside
of cells that you may have never heard
of and that we love to let blow our
minds this is the unicellular alga kloss
terraeum and at the very tips of these
cells an alluring little object you see
that orb or the tiny round things inside
well those are actually crystals made of
barium and calcium sulfate but why are
they there well no one knows yet
and we hope nay we know someone will
someday solve this mystery but for now
it is yet another thing that we do not
know about our universe these crystals
are extremely small around two to three
microns across if you divided a
millimeter into 500 equal pieces one of
those pieces is how big those little
grains are but there's more you see how
those crystals jiggle around and never
stop
even though nothing seems to be moving
them well one thing we know about the
universe is that things don't just move
the energy has to be coming from
somewhere let's remember that everything
you're looking at here is made of atoms
and when two hydrogen atoms and one
oxygen atom come together they form a
water molecule now kloss terraeum lives
in water which means it's surrounded by
and filled with water molecules and they
are in constant motion
that's what heat is the movement of
atoms and molecules if they weren't
moving at all that would be absolute
zero negative 273 0.15 degrees Celsius
that's not what we're at these water
molecules are moving around a lot and
they're bumping into everything they can
even move objects around if something's
really big like a whole class terraeum
cell you can't actually see any movement
but since these crystals are so tiny the
water molecules visibly toss them around
this dancing is called
Brownian motion and we love it because
we of course cannot see water molecules
under the microscope but we can observe
their effect on these crystals indeed
Albert Einstein used Brownian motion to
confirm that atoms and molecules exist
which in 1905 when he published his
paper on the subject was still a matter
of debate and now or watching it happen
watching water molecules smashing around
into crystals that as yet remain
unexplained but must have some reason to
exist
besides being fun for us to look at
[Music]
this is NASA la or nada a beautiful
unicellular ciliate although it doesn't
look like it right now they can move
quite fast what you are looking at is a
squashed masala or nada we decided to
give it a bit of a squeeze so we could
take a real good look
when Nestle we're not a hunts for food
it prefers filamentous cyanobacteria or
algae it wraps its membrane around it
forming a food vacuole as it continues
to eat it forms more and more of these
vacuoles now what's so nice about them
are their colors cyanobacteria and algae
NASA was food are green but when NASA
starts dumping digestive enzymes into
these food vacuole a chemical reaction
occurs changing the color of the food
vacuole over time because different
vacuoles are at different stages of
digestion each vacuole is a slightly
different color giving this ciliate its
beautiful colored polka dots these are
the very long very skinny cells of the
filamentous sulfur bacterium edgy at Toa
you can find them all over the globe
living in habitats for marine caves to
Sulphur Springs to everyday ponds and
rivers when we find them they're usually
on freshwater ponds sediments or
decomposing organic material bed Jia Toa
excretes mucus which allows them to
glide around on the sediments the jia
TOA prefers sulfur rich environments
because they oxidize hydrogen sulfide as
an energy source the hydrogen is used by
the organism in chemical synthesis and
the sulfur is left over every one of
those tiny black dots that use
is a granule of inorganic sulphur here's
another clip where you can look at them
a bit closer under 1000 times
magnification which for the moment is
about as good as we can do here now
what's happening here these little
bubbles forming and popping well they're
not bubbles of air they're bubbles of
pure water one of the most fundamental
structures for life as a freshwater
single-celled organism is the
contractile vacuole this organelle
allows unicellular organisms to pump
excess water from their cell why well
inside of every cell there are a lot of
dissolved substances more than the
surrounding water contains certainly
whenever there's an imbalance like this
things tend toward equilibrium and the
only thing separating these cells from
the water around them has a membrane
that allows some but not all substances
to pass through it passively one of
those substances is water when the
concentration of stuff inside the cell
is higher than the concentration of
stuff outside water diffuses into the
cell there is no way to stop this
diffusion the solution to this constant
influx of water is the contractile
vacuole this organelle fights a
continuous battle pumping and pumping
and pumping the water out imagine though
if the contractile vacuole was not
working you might think that eventually
the cell would fill with so much water
that the cellular machinery might break
down well maybe except before that
happened the cell would expand so much
that its membrane would break and it
would literally explode
so you know
good job little vacuole the ciliate Lux
ODIs is a common resident of different
aquatic habitats but they prefer a
distinct zone in the water a Goldilocks
zone for oxygen they like the
concentration to be not too high and not
too low and in the body of water unless
something weird is going on the oxygen
concentration is higher at the top and
lower toward the bottom because of its
specific oxygen concentration preference
locks ODIs needs to know which way is up
and which way is down so it can find
just the right spot but how could a
single-celled organism know up from down
well luck sodas can sense gravity it has
organelles called muller vesicles that
each contain a spherical mineral granule
the muller body attached to a hair like
psyllium sorry these friends zip around
so quick it could be hard to get a good
look these granules the Muller bodies
are actually pulled down by gravity and
it's believed that this pulling causes
sensory signals to be transmitted to the
cell through the psyllium so Lux Otis
despite being tiny and despite being
just a single cell has an organ very
much like our inner ear allowing it to
sense up from down so yes microbes
display quite the collection of
intracellular structures only a few of
which we discussed here some shiny some
colorful and some that provide
fascinating advanced capabilities and it
makes us wonder what other structures
are yet to be discovered there is so
much that we do not know we hope to
report back to you on this question
because we are sure that there are many
more out there just waiting to be
unveiled
by a discerning eye peering into the
micro cosmos if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes James
check out Jam and germs on Instagram and
if you want to see more from us here at
journey to the micro cosmos I bet
there's a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
[Music]
you